moi j'ai découvert en fait venu piquer
bien avec qu'il y avait un homme dans la
vie de l'une de mes femmes ne fait pas
la citer alors on va dire justin
d'autres cas mais vous aimez écouter
cette histoire parce que je pense qu'on
peut pas vivre pire en fait on se tait
c'est pas un peu avant les vacances de
noël la dasté le 21 décembre à décembre
21 décembre est en fait donc
la future ex-femme parents en vacances
avec avec ses enfants avec ses parents
et comme on est en séparation ont sapé
de temps en temps mais je suis parti à
los angeles évidemment si tu vas pas
rasé au bout de trois heures donc le
dossier de mon côté j'étais un petit peu
nous charger un petit peu géré compris
donc toi tu avais quelqu'un
qu'il y avait quelqu'un dans la vie de
ma femme vous êtes en train de dire que
votre femme avait accueilli une star à
domicile
[Applaudissements]
écoutez c'est parce qu'elle est folle
donc on s'appelait parce qu'il fallait
prendre des nouvelles du petit etc bref
et puis elle fit tomber son téléphone
dans la mer donc on a tout téléphone
portable ah oui et puis dont elle
m'appelle dit voilà pour ce que j'en
sais un peu compliqué elle me donne à
nouveau numéro téléphone xpath le temps
qu'il se passe chacun revient de
vacances et je rentre chez moi c'est
encore chez moi et je retrouve le
téléphone qui ne marchaient plus bas
était censé ne plus marcher oui mais
après ça ça sèche et voilà et donc ça cg
écrire c'est l'effet j'ai allumé le
portable voyez pas de code bah je
l'avais non oui et là j'ai été là en
fait j'ai découvert non
tout l'historique des gones historiques
comme l'historique de son histoire avec
avec l'autre j'ai fui la rencontre c'est
là la
lad rad la première nuit des étoiles et
dans les commentaires
j'habite inquiète pas il n'a rien vu
et en fait en fait là le monde s'écroule
vous avez les heures les dates non aux
punaises j'étais là bas c'était un truc
c'était encore ensemble ouais bah oui
[Rires]
et plus vous avancez dans les textos et
plus vous voyez est plus en fait on se
décomposerait cessa hamas est atroce le
saviez votre coalition code belge avait
100 par mois je savais alors je vais
vous dire moi j'ai une règle d'or c'est
parce que c'est pas une question alors
qu'ils ont confiance et d'amitié c'est
une question j'ai mon jardin
si mon jardin secret jamais et c'est au
grand jamais je ne passerai mon
téléphone a mal à me dire si mal rien
déjà vous dire je ne sais pas pourquoi
j'ai rien à cacher mais dicté ma meuf
pro montel j'ai une montée
dès qu'elle voulait partir et je suis
dans un amas non mais sans déconner elle
pour monthey le coma et je sais pas
pourquoi en fait pour rien parce que
rien à cacher
je pensais peut-être que mon téléphone à
des trucs à cacher
la change
elle prend ton tel mon frère métier et
je vais des poils peut faire des photos
et attend même parce que j'ai plus tu
peux faire une photo oui
mais maintenant oui mais vite japon n'a
pas d'importance
mais c'est ouais tu pas laisser passer
de bélaye el-alia ce truc incroyable
avec tabary c-49 saucats honte elle est
là
et un moment et un vote mais bon pas
l'exhaustivité de son téléphone c'est
pas un jeu j'ai des appels importants
bien celle qui tombe à peine abonnement
à l'autre